Welcome, everybody to another Zoom call.
It is, uh, evident this September.
I think this is the eighth year that we've been doing these in calls.
This is year eight.
So, that's kind of cool.
I think we started this September eight years ago.
August or September eight years ago.
Okay, let's get started.
Reminder to everybody to look at the member's home page for any announcements.
There were no new amount of announcements today.
But let's jump in and get to the questions.
If you have a question that you think of that you do not get submitted,
make sure you just chat that question in and we'll get to it.
First question, what's supplement?
Should I take to lower my whole system levels?
So, whole system is a metabolite that, um,
later changes to system and goes into the cycle to help produce glutathione
among other things.
It's the endpoint of what's called the methane cycle.
And, uh, it can be elevated because of deficiencies in methyl groups.
So, typically, if person has elevated homocysteine,
you want to increase methyl groups, which typically is contraindicatory for cancer patients.
So, cancer patients don't necessarily want to add exogenous methyl groups.
You don't want to take supplements that have methyl folate,
methyl tetrahedral folate, or methylcobolamine,
because excess methyl groups can bind to and silence tumor suppressor genes
thereby allowing cancers to continue to flourish.
So, their silencing or turning off tumor suppressor genes in your tumor suppressor gene system
is the intrinsic meaning inside the cell way that your body will kill, uh,
destroy cancer cells.
So, you'll have an internal switch inside each cell if a cancer,
if a cell becomes a cancer cell, then it goes into rapid replication.
By tumor suppressor genes that will turn out and stimulate apoptotic or cell death cycles inside the cell.
Excess methyl groups, if I'm taking methylcobolamine, methyl tetrahedral folate,
because, you know, my nutritionist told me that I should take that,
um, that that can actually be something that could propagate a cancer.
So, um, and that can be part of a reason why a person has a cancer
and it gets a diagnosis cancer because they were taking that, um, indirectly.
So, the only reason why I would have somebody take methyl groups is if we did a blood test
and they had elevated levels of homocysteine.
Homocysteine, again, is a metabolite that then converts to, um,
uh, it's like it converts to, uh, another metabolite, another intermediate metabolite goes in through the CTH gene
and breaks down into cysteine, um, and then it helps produce glutathione and cysteine sulfate
and some other different intermediate metabolites.
Um, but if a person has elevated homocysteine, it can damage the internal lighting of your vessel
so it can damage the endothelial layer and that's what can end up causing your body will try
to heal that through cholesterol, placking, and cholesterol gets the bad AIDS and is that becoming the bad guy.
And that's what can, um, block arteries and it's really not cholesterol's fault.
It's an elevation in the homocysteine.
So, getting homocysteine levels checked is a good idea.
Now, it's not always a part of a comprehensive metabolic profile so many times you need to request that.
Um, so getting homocysteine levels checked is a good idea.
If your homocysteine is within normal limits, then I would not use exogenous methyl groups.
Um, regardless of whether if you have MTHFR gene defects or not.
Again, for those that have been with me for a long time, you've heard me talk about, you know, MTHFR,
methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase gene, and many people that, um, ignorantly, um, just take methyl groups
because they have an MTHFR gene defect, thinking that because I have that defect, I need to be taking methyl groups.
I think that's incorrect on many levels and it could be actually dangerous.
Not just for propagated cancer, but it pushes the biopterate pathway to cause excess serotonin at dopamine levels,
especially if you have defects in the, um, uh, the genes in different genes in the biopterate pathway, the COTG, the MAO gene.
And the, um, um, other pathways that lead to dopamine production.
So, but if you do have elevated homocysteine that I would say you take methyl groups for a period of time,
you recheck and you play with your dosage based upon that homocysteine level.
Next question.
I would like to increase my understanding of the right machine. I am a side sleeper, I'm supporting breast cancer.
I alternate sleeping on my sides.
The light is in the middle of the bed.
So, on my left side, it's on my front, and on my right side, it's on my back.
Is this usage acceptable?
Yes. So, that usage would be acceptable, um, because the right is putting out enough voltage and amperage that it's penetrating your body.
So, whether it's right up against your body on the, your back or right up against your body on the front.
Now, of course, if you have breast cancer, you're not having to penetrate your lungs and your rib cage and your back muscles.
Uh, if it's going through your front, it's going right to the breast.
But remember, you have circulated tumor cells that have settled all over your body and in your lungs as well and in your spine as well.
So, you have a, you know, rollover on the side and have certain percentage of the time that it's hit your back, certain percentage of the time that it's hit your front is perfectly acceptable.
Also, I have a AA folder, AA, your name, and a AA 11X folder.
Should I be using both or alternating? No, you're, you're, um, if I updated your folder sets March.
Um, I don't remember who has asked this question, but if I've, I've updated your folder sets March, it has, it is the folder.
So, if you're, if, if you're folder that you're using, it says AA, your name, and then a date.
Then it is, um, and we're talking to only people with, uh, till you rob it here with this question.
Then you do your, your program is fully equipped with 11 harmonic frequencies.
Um, I believe I've done that with everybody. So, um, if not, let me know.
So, if you say, no, I have not, you have not updated my program, uh, uh, since I bought it in November or something, then let me know.
But if it has a date after it, then it has the, uh, it has the 11th harmonic and you don't need to use that AA 11X folder at all.
Okay, next question. I have a very old computer for my right.
I think it's a Windows 7 that I got from you about 15 years ago and I started with you.
Should I replace it? It seems to be working just fine.
No, you should replace it. Um, yeah, quite honestly, so with those old computers back 15 years ago.
Um, we're better quality than the ones you can purchase today.
Um, uh, I have a number of people that started with me 15, 20 years ago that are still using the Windows 7 computer that came with their right.
And it still works, which is a testimony for a little laptop.
Um, so don't, you don't need to replace it.
Don't just keep going with it. There's no, there's no reason to replace it.
Um, I think every single person I've updated their program to be a, this would be a true right now.
I've updated their program to be version 6 or version 6.4, which is you don't need anything beyond that.
Still have some people that are still run in version 5.5, but it's working just fine and it's working with their program to find that they've been in remission for 15 years.
So I'll think we did change anything. So no, keep keep going.
Next question.
While a lot of break from chemo, do you think I would benefit from taking a daily binder?
Um, yeah, I think it would be good for everybody to be taking a binder.
Um, do they need to take it daily all the time?
Not necessarily. It depends on if they're in remission or not.
What's the purpose of a binder? Technically a binder is something that you're not really absorbing.
It's staying in your gut and it's binding things in your, in your, in your large intestine primarily so that you don't reabsorb them so that you then will finish the detoxification process and dump those things in the toilet.
So remember, when your liver is detoxifying and getting things, you're filtering your blood, anything's out of your blood.
It puts it into the bile and then the bile is deposited deposited in the first part of the small intestine called the duodenum and it has to go 30 feet before it gets into the toilet.
And there's times as it goes, those 30 feet, if we have leaky gut issues, if we have a very slow intestinal transit time, then we have the possibility of reabsorbing those toxins that deliver work so darn hard, getting rid of.
And then we reabsorb it. It goes black into the bloodstream and then our liver sees it again and goes, what in the world are you doing here again?
It didn't I dump you three days ago and it goes has to go through the processing.
Well, I don't know if the liver really does, but we don't want that to happen.
So the benefit of using using binders, now technically we get binders at our food if we're eating fiber, fiber is a binder.
So it grabs out the things, it keeps you from reabsorbing it. It's not digestible.
So indigestible fiber is a binder and then you it goes out in the waste and you deposit it into the toilet.
So there isn't anything wrong with using a binder even when you're on chemo. Some people will say no, you shouldn't use a binder when you're on chemo because you could bind the chemo and you could you could lose the benefits of the chemo.
No, no, by definition a binder is stayed in your intestinal tract.
If the chemo has already gone through your detoxification pathways and is in your intestines, you want to dump it into the toilet.
You've already you've already detoxified it. You don't want to reabsorb it.
So you could be taking a binder when you're doing chemo therapy.
So you don't need to only do it when you're on a break or not do it when you're not on a break.
Would you do a key later when you're doing chemo therapy? Well, maybe not.
A key later is you could think of it as a binder, but you're absorbing those things typically something other than a binder.
It's something different that is absorbable. You absorb that thing like DMSA or other different things that will grab onto stuff in the tissues in your cells and pull it out of the cells into the blood so that you will detoxify it.
Well, if you're taking about your key laders, while you're doing chemo therapy, you have the potential, I guess a key lady don't, the chemo and getting less benefit from the chemo.
So really you get the benefit of the chemo really within the first 48 hours after an IV administration.
So technically you could do key laders again after 48 hours if you're trying to key laid out other toxins in your body and you're trying to mitigate the negative effects of the chemo that would be happening as well.
So answer yes on this question would be appropriate.
The same person asked, I have been out of six week break from chemo because of terrible neuropathy from the chemo in the last six weeks by uncle and phosphatase.
A shot up to 268 by ALT to 361 by AST to 191, six weeks ago they were normal or near normal.
The only change I made during this time is to start taking SEAC tea. Do you think the SEAC tea would be causing this increase?
My oncologist thinks it's the cancer, but he does not know about me taking the SEAC.
Anything is possible. So if you have elevation of alkaline phosphatase but you don't have elevation of ALT and AST, then you don't think that it's, I mean it's still possible but it's a little lesser degree chance that it's something going on of the liver itself.
You start thinking of tissue damage elsewhere. So if you have a known cancer, you look at, if my alkaline phosphatase is elevated by ALT and AST is spared, then you think that it's a metastasis to bone.
That's the most common thing you would see. If you have ALT elevated AST elevated like this question along with alkaline phosphatase, then you think the irritation or the problem is in the liver itself.
So I would say that yes, it's possibly the SEAC tea could be just, you know, it could be something in that herb combination that your liver just doesn't like.
I would for sure test that by just going off of that. Could it be the cancer? Well, if it is the cancer, it would be more likely that the cancer is metastasis to the liver than it is because the cancer is growing in the breast
or growing in the lung or growing in the intestinal tract or even metastasized to bone because typically if you have cancer growing in any of those things I just mentioned or metastasized to bone, it wouldn't increase ALT and AST.
So again, the most common reason for increased alkaline phosphatase ALT and AST is the drug as a medication, even Tylenol, pain medication will do that.
So if you're not at 80 medications whatsoever, the only change you made is SEAC tea that I would say, well, I would definitely go off SEAC tea and see if it decreases.
If you, let's say, if it has nothing to do with cancer, it has something to do with irritation of the liver because something you're taking.
And let's say it was SEAC tea and you went off of it, these numbers should come back to normal relatively quickly or if it was Tylenol, all I'm taking Tylenol every day, well, if you were able to get off of that, these numbers should go down.
So I would investigate anything you're taking, it could be, it's very common that Tylenol does this.
So you look at if you're taking something like that or other pain medication or ad bill, but definitely if you're not taking any of those things, I would go off the SEAC tea and then wait a few weeks and see if the numbers stabilize or start to decrease.
Okay, we had a couple of questions from the chat. What can I take for H. Pylori? Well, that was a question last week that I went into detail and I have a blog post about H. Pylori, too.
So make sure you look at the blog about H. Pylori.
Top things for H. Pylori would be, you know, or a great burberry, oregano, garlic, those would be the top things that you would take for H. Pylori.
And then, and leaky got has come back to challenge my digestion. So, you know, everybody has issues with leaky got.
And, you know, just because of our American diet, the level of toxicity that we're living with, the level of cross contamination with glyphosate is the biggest thing that's going to damage your gut lining.
And we're all exposed to that, probably on a daily basis.
So, we have to always be working on leaky gut. So, there's a lot of leaky gut supplements out there.
Things with slippery elmen and a marshmallow root and declycerized licorice and so I like a product called GI sood.
It's a zyvogen product because it's just a tablet that you put in your mouth and you dissolve it. It's a chocolate flavor tablet. Super easy to take.
But there's other products, the only thing you have to be careful with with cancer diagnosis, a lot of he got healing products will have elglutamine in it.
You don't want to be taking that. At least you don't want to be taking high doses of that for a very long period of time with cancer diagnosis because elglutamine is such a growth factor to cancer.
But I do have videos and blog posts on both of these. So, make sure you look at that. I go into that in greater detail.
Okay, question about that. We'll go back to this question. My program was updated in February. I could look at that tomorrow and see, make sure I have 11th harmonic in your program and I will let you know if you don't.
If I need to update that, I will. But if you have updated in February, I think it's got the 11th harmonic in it. So you don't have to worry about doing that that extra one.
And then a question about this elevated ALT, AST and Oakland Foss, not taking Tylenol or any other painkillers that I would definitely suspect SCRT.
If a person, there wasn't taking anything and they had a diagnosis of cancer and they had a rapid increase in those three liver markers, you do.
I would agree with the oncologist. You'd suspect metastasis to the liver.
Or if you had no metastasis in the liver, you'd suspect, you know, increase activity in the liver. That's what you'd suspect.
If you don't have metastasis to the liver right now, then I wouldn't necessarily jump to that. I'd say, well, I did change it. I took this different supplement or something.
Or you're making a comment, I have had metastasis to the liver for over two years with the normal numbers. Then, then if you have no metastasis in the liver, then I would then switch my answer to.
I might agree with the oncologist that you might want to get a CT or MRI, whatever they use to see the size of the legions in the liver before.
Because that's a greater possibility than the SEAC doing that.
If he, if your oncologist is he, if he's wanting to get imaging, I think I might agree with that. That might be a good idea.
Do not have a chance to look at that article yet, sorry. Any other questions?
I think you have alluded to bone broth before, but is that okay for cancer patients?
So bone broth is typically used to help heal the gut. Why does bone broth work to heal the gut? What's that? Is there something magic in bone broth?
Well, what's in bone broth? When you take beef bones or chicken bones, you put them in water and you cook them for three days.
You're basically drawing a lot of nutrients out of the bone. When you're done making bone broth, you could basically eat the bone because it's just soft.
Typically, when you're trying to heal the gut, you can eat the bones, except maybe a big beef bone, but definitely chicken bone when you make chicken bone broth.
You could eat the bones, and it would be good for you. But the reason why bone broth is so good to help heal leaky gut is because you're drawing so much glutamine out of the bones.
The amount of glutamine in bone broth is super high. That's why it's so good to help heal the gut.
Because glutamine helps cell turnover, helps cells reproduce, really stimulates reproduction of epithelial cells.
And that's the light need of the gutter epithelial cells. Well, if you have cancer, you don't want to be turning on growth factors for epithelial cells.
So I wouldn't use bone broth for a person that has cancer. Well, let's say my cancer is in remission. I'm doing really well. Could you use bone broth for a short period of time to help heal the gut?
Yes, I would say yes, you can. But for a short period of time, maybe a week.
And then go back to other things. There's a lot of other things other than elglutamine that you can use to help heal the gut.
So it's not like your gut's not going to heal if you don't take elglutamine or bone broth without high concentrations about glutamates. It's not necessary.
So I would tend to just stay away from it. Next comment. I'd love it if I do it till you rob it. I just wanted you to know what a blessing this is to be.
Oh, that's so heartwarming to me. That's fantastic. Thank you for that. Any other questions?
Okay, well, I just want to say in light of the horrific things that have happened this last week.
I just think it should be a reminder to us that we live in a fallen world and there are enemy once us dead.
So you could say that with dealing with cancer, with dealing with everything that it's a reminder for us to stay focused on.
Spreading the gospel and being, you know, working on our relationship has ultimately got to allow things in our life.
The death of friends, disease and sickness, you know, us to experience the fallenness of this world to drive all for the purpose to drive us closer to him.
But the death brings him glory. So let all these things drive us closer to him more towards our purpose and understanding our purpose.
So if we keep that in our mind, you said, could you repeat the name of the God supplement you like the most? It's the GI sued.
It's a lawsuit. GI sued. It's an image and product.
All right. With that, God bless everybody. Keep praying. He prayed for us. All your fellow cancer mates here and our God to reveal his vision and purpose ultimately for you.
It know that we're praying for you. All right. Bye-bye.